de verdad a parís estos soldados han
corrido más de 360 kilómetros en honor a
ocho compañeros oficiales que perdieron
la vida durante la primera guerra
mundial
son los soldados desconocidos de francia
sus identidades siguen siendo un
misterio sus cuerpos fueron enterrados
el 11 de noviembre de 1920 siete de
ellos en verdad mientras que sólo uno
fue seleccionado al azar para ser
llevado a su lugar de descanso final en
parís bajo el arco de triunfo
ahora cien años después los oficiales
franceses presentan sus respetos con una
carrera por todo el país y el cubo
corren llevando sus rifles con bolsas el
objetivo es honrarlos a través del
esfuerzo estos ocho equipos de soldados
siguiendo el rastro del viaje de los
ataúdes desde las trincheras de verdad
hasta la capital francesa llevando
consigo la llama eterna fue encendida
por primera vez en 1923 y ahora es un
símbolo de todos los que murieron
luchando por francia
es un gran honor llevar la llama eterna
representa un vínculo entre nuestros
predecesores que murieron en combate y
las tropas de hoy
debido a las restricciones del
coronavirus la ceremonia tradicional en
los campos elíseos ha sido reducida pero
el presidente francés emmanuel macrón
puso una corona en la tumba del soldado
desconocido solo un número de oficiales
militares asistieron a la ceremonia para
reavivar la simbólica llama